I have decided in 2020 to run for
president it's true Kanye West announced
he's running for president in 2020 and
he opened up about his plans for the
White House in a bombshell interview
with Forbes earlier this week the world
would be a better place but now a source
tells et that while the Kardashians
support Kanye they don't agree with some
of the things he said during his four
hour-long wide-ranging sit-down just a
little refresher during his chat with
the mag Kanye admitted that he's never
voted before that he believes vaccines
are the mark of the beast oh and he
envisions a White House organizational
model based on the fictional country of
Wakanda in black panther now et source
says that Kanye's family is supportive
of his plans to run for president but
they weren't down with his recent
interview
well Kim will always support Kanye but
she doesn't have to always agree with
him and that's what makes their
relationship special I've seen him go
through a lot and he's just the most
genuine person and you know he might say
things that might get misinterpreted and
people don't see the context behind it
but I always know his heart the source
added that while his family will always
support him in his endeavors they also
worry for him quote Kanye has a tendency
to overwork himself physically
emotionally and mentally and not take
time to rest and reset I feel like I
have a responsibility all of this comes
after reports claim that the rapper is
in the midst of a bipolar episode I
think it's important for us to have
conversations about you know open
conversations about mental health
especially with me being black because
we never had therapists in the black
community we never approach like taking
medication Kanye has been candid about
his struggle with mental health in the
past opening up on Jimmy Kimmel Live in
2018 there's some cases of bipolar where
people go low I'm one that goes high
it's like like Michelle Obama see they
don't have extreme periods of
of depression and Kanye said that even
with his highs and lows he's proud that
he's managed to accomplish a whole lot I
want to prove that you can get fat you
can say the wrong things you can piss a
home and you can be President of the
United States
[Laughter]
[Music]